sur la foi de fausses photos francfort
dow jones les djihadistes qui ne
regrette rien j'en ai rencontré
plusieurs en syrie au mois de décembre
pour brut j'ai pu pénétrer dans une des
prisons kurdes où sont détenus 5000
membres présumés de l'êta islamique en
mars 2010neuf l'état islamique perd la
bataille de ben arous
cette défaite marque la fin territoriale
de dèche en syrie mais une question
majeure se pose depuis que faire des
djihadistes qui ont été arrêtés ainsi
que leurs familles nous demandent de
devoir justifier des actes qu'on n'a pas
commis répondre de certains crimes qu'on
n'a pas commis non plus épris de voir
passer dans une spirale judiciaire qui
va ajouter encore plus de mal que ces
cinq ans de guerre on veut pas rentrer
chez nous après je prends des besoins de
pigeons d'appeler ou le pain des deux
genoux comme de trousser les forces
spéciales coeur n'ont posé deux
conditions pour que je puisse pénétrer
dans cette prison ultra surveillé et
ultra surpeuplée que je ne filme pas
l'extérieur du bâtiment pour des
questions de sécurité et que je ne parle
pas aux détenus de l'actualité pour
éviter une révolte
on ne leur a toujours pas dit que
aboubakar al-bagdadi l'ancien chef de
dèche a été tué par les américains
[Musique]
on pouvait le voir toutes les pièces
sont bondés
quasiment pas de place pour se déplacer
il n'y a quasiment pas de lumière du
jour la seule lumière du jour qui
filtrent c'est ce petit boulot là haut
pour certains ont été emprisonnés il ya
neuf mois
jamais sorti de cette pièce
ils passent tout leur temps ici ce que
je vous porte avec mon doigt c'est les
toilettes de la cellule est juste à
droite la balle c'est là où ils se
nettoient
[Musique]
impatient que j'utilise
bidons d'eau selon m
une odeur très forte qui se dégage de la
cellule c'est limite du respirable
[Musique]
djihadistes de dèche que je pouvoir
interviewer n'arrive en quelques
semaines
les bombes à dingle coupe rupo pis pour
le thon expect latino notre cas liés à
cette famille sauf omis ou killing
operating son goût sont mis à dos ok
c'est bon de s'intéresser au monde de
nos candidats fera pas au mythe a quant
à lui me fabre
pour vous compreniez bien la situation
dans la pièce il y à moi et ma caméra
mais il ya aussi le chef de la prison et
plusieurs membres des forces spéciales
kurde est pourtant très vite
le djihadiste britannique attaque
ouvertement ses geôliers et dénonce ses
conditions de détention d'eysses
[Musique]
le chef de la prison est un membre des
forces spéciales kurde et évidemment il
n'a pas le même discours que le
djihadiste britannique que je vient
d'interroger de british insiste un peu
de temps d'un week end en europe
je veux toucher qui tenait de magoula
week-end à misano quoi lever davantage
sur une verte et ses mains comme laurent
blanc son terme la syrah une sans crise
reebok rétinol de cmed je vais rouler
invite xiam nan je vais regarder leurs
images marquent la nakba sagnette anna
cabana en a raté la galerie musée
national vannes et nous avons de la case
et de stéphane denis ne nous embêtent
qui jean d'âcre et des beach boys band
take you down under et des tentative de
mutinerie il y en a déjà eu plusieurs au
cours des derniers mois on peut voir sur
ces images une technique fréquentes en
des djihadistes attire les gars de
kurdes en faisant semblant de mourir
et quand les portes s'ouvrent les
prisonniers attaque
et du coup partout dans la prison il
faut rester extrêmement prudent
particulièrement dans l'hôpital où j'ai
pu aller et où près de 300 prisonniers
sont entassés
donc là je vais rentrer dans l'hôpital
m
ach a toujours laissé passer le garde en
premier
je peux pas m'avancer plus
peut-être ils ont expliqué que plus on
va loin dans la salle s'il ya le moindre
problème
puis c'est difficile de revenir vers la
porte d'entrée
black swan jean bédard n'est que
l'élection ait dissuadé certains me
garder mais aussi l impressionnant
la vente avait
et 80 il ya aussi pas mal de gens qui
sont extrêmement maigre très affaiblis
qu'ils doivent souffrir de malnutrition
voire de malnutrition sévère aiguë c'est
à dire qu'ils sont clairement sous
alimentés il ya beaucoup de blessés par
balles a dans cet hôpital
il joue à beaucoup de gens et des
fixateurs externes des plaies au niveau
des bras des jambes donc lui clairement
si une blessure de guerre il a dû
prendre une balle dans la jambe
il ya aussi une odeur très forte c'est
pour ça qu'on doit porter des masques
c'est un peu une odeur pestilentielle je
ne sais pas s'ils peuvent se doucher
mais j'ai pas l'impression
ils ont qu'une toilette alors qu ils
sont 300 dans cette salle et au milieu
de tous ces malades
j'ai pu interviewer abdallah un jeune
djihadistes belge de 24 ans qui est
détenu ici depuis neuf mois et qui a
rejoint l'état islamique en 2014 tu à
venir regrette comme une poussière grise
aucun exemple
à regret
[Musique]
[Rires]
où
nous
je suis dans le camp j'ai en dallol
vivent les familles de l'état islamique
il ya principalement des femmes et des
enfants 70 mille personnes vivent ici
dans des conditions extrêmement
précaires
moi c'est le marché pour les femmes
étrangères et leurs familles ici elle
achète des vêtements et à manger et pour
acheter tout ça il ya un magasin dans
lequel elles peuvent retirer de l'argent
qu'on leur emploi depuis l'étranger
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes française bah je suis
venue pour rencontrer des françaises oui
je suis français quel âge vous avez vous
mais d'où rien partie de la scène
comment vous vivez ici c'est quoi la
situation sanitaire qu'on a du mal à se
chauffer qu'est-ce qu'il fait très fort
on est entourés d'adultes ou tissus et
nous donne pas à manger ou alors c'est
quelque chose qui nous donne la diarrhée
pendant des semaines il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'associations de manille terre
qui a fait l'association du tout il ya
plein de lapins de médecins pas de
filiale
qu'est ce que vous faisiez vous au salon
n'est pas islamique javier de travail
donc j'étais à la maison donc à la
maison femme au foyer font le ménage à
manger pas franchement c'était c'était
bien je vais bien
on avait deux maisons on avait nos avons
fait chacun on en avait chacun dans un
appartement pour viviez avec nos maris
avec nos enfants y avait des parts qui
avaient des hôpitaux il y avait des
écoles
c'était la vie normale comme en france
en fait sauf que l'on pouvait vivre
notre islam en paix c'est que dans
vraiment quand ils ont commencé à
attaquer leurs cas que les jeunes ont
commencé à fuir fut vraiment on a
ressenti la guerre comme beaucoup de
djihadistes ces français originaire de
la région parisienne et du sud de la
france continue de défendre leur mode de
vie
sous le règne de l'état islamique mais
face à la caméra elle critique aussi des
ch
je veux plus du tout être affiliés il me
représente pas je les représente pas je
ne veux pas être affiliés leur idéologie
puisque pour moi c'est pas ça l'islam
mais je suis musulmane et je le resterai
jusqu'à ma mort
qu'est ce qui n'était pas moi les
attentats suicides y lisons à légiférer
alors que c'est interdit
les conditions de la guerre c'est pas
comme ça quand la réputation sinon c'est
une grande propagande et tout s'est
décanté quelqu'un sait pas c'est pas
naturel
c'est pas naturel ça évidemment ça dit
quelque chose c'est bien sûr quand on
voit ça c'est choquant après c'est sûr
que me dit que le discours il peut être
n'est pas très crédible au vu de la
situation en pensant que tout le monde
pense qu'on est dans la même idéologie
en fait dans la vie on fait des choses
et on n'était pas bien et des choses
bien et là on a fait des choses pas très
bien on a ça je ne peux pas dire quand
je regarde mon agissements je regarde
pas de détrôner parce que c'est le
destin mais ouais je regrette d avoir
cru je redonne d avoir cru je leur en
veux j'ai pas j'ai pas une reparti je
regrette ce que j'ai fait n'est j'assume
et je suis contente de du parcours que
lui parce que j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses weiss et quitter l'état islamique
garde on a essayé c'est un coach n'a pas
essayé d'une vérité qui n'a pas essayé
la dernière année j'ai essayé même sans
ça on a essayé de quitter parce que
c'était plus possible cette équipe
possible c'était comme si c'était plus
comme au début ou danser nos sécurités
ont viré en tête c'était devenu même il
était devenu complètement injuste dans
leur manière de faire avec nous ils
étaient même près c'était devenu aussi
nos oppresseurs plus que les labos il
est sûr que la coalition était devenu
presque on était finalement on avait
deux d'aliens donc on voulait vraiment
pas sortir de chez eux mais
malheureusement ils m'ont coupé la route
ils nous empêcher de sortir si on essaie
de sortir on met en prison
moi j'étais en prison chez eux parce que
c'est mon avis partir jusqu'à ce que
doit se
une demande de devoir justifier des
actes on n'a pas commis répondre de
certains crimes qu'on n'a pas commis non
plus et devoir payer tout j'ai une peine
en france donc séparé des enfants chose
que on n'accepte pas pour rejette
totalement parce qu'on n'a rien commis
on n'a rien fait et si on peut rentrer
pour mener une vie normale avec nos
familles à problèmes et c'est heureux de
voir passer dans une spirale judiciaire
qui va donner encore plus de mal que ces
cinq ans de guerre on veut pas rentrer
en france
des retours de femmes et d'enfants de
dèche de toute façon pour le moment ça
se fait au compte gouttes en france et
tout en rentrant on affaire à la justice
si ce reportage vous a intéressé
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
de brut pour ne pas rater le prochain
documentaire a très vite